I don't know if folks are aware, but we have
to keep covering it.
Corona virus cases have exploded again with
the most cases in the United States in two
months.
And new records in 13 states.
Now, I know that the Republican Party and
the Trump administration and the Trump campaign
are acting as if it's over, as if nothing's
going on.
We saw Koven positive Republican Senator Mike
Lee taking his mask off indoors.
Around 80 year olds at yesterday's Amy CONI
Barrat Supreme Court hearings.
Trump is doing rallies again.
But we do have a pandemic going on and it's
not.
Going so well, the latest numbers are that
on October 9th.
So that's Friday, I think.
Friday, Saturday, Friday, over the weekend,
we had just shy of sixty one thousand new
cases in one day.
That's the most new cases in a single day,
dating back almost two months to August 14th.
As you probably know by now.
Deaths lag cases by two to three weeks.
We've now seen what was a declining death
trend level off.
It's now flat and in all likelihood, it's
already happened twice before.
During this pandemic, when cases spike, deaths
spike two to three weeks later.
That's at the national level.
Now, there are 13 states, most of them in
the western Midwest, that have new records
for coronavirus infections over the last week.
These are seven day rolling averages, which
is a better indicator than just a single day.
New seven day rolling average highs in Alaska,
Colorado, Indiana, Minnesota, Montana, Nebraska,
New Mexico, North Dakota, Ohio, Oklahoma,
Oregon, South Dakota and Wisconsin.
The worst of which are in Montana, New Mexico
and South Dakota.
Now, you might come in and say, oh, but.
But, but, but.
But, but, David.
Clucking like a chicken.
But what about hospitalizations?
Well, Indiana, North Dakota, Montana and Nebraska
reporting record high numbers of Corona virus
hospitalizations.
On Sunday, same with Utah.
So hospitalizations are going up.
So understand that no matter how many times
Trump says it's disappearing, instead of we've
turned the corner, he says, we rounded the
turn.
I understand he's trying to say we turned
the corner.
Thirteen out of 50 states have new record
highs.
That's new peaks in more than a quarter of
American states.
And even in states that aren't at new highs,
numbers are climbing.
I mean, look, even here in Massachusetts,
for example, we were down to about 150 cases
per day for months.
We've now once again started to get into the
300 cases per day in September.
400 cases per day at the end of September.
Six hundred case days in October so far.
So it is coming back exactly as predicted.
It's not just flu season.
We have college students flying around the
country and spreading.
We have schools, a number of schools having
to very quickly shut things down.
And also that people are exhausted, which
I understand not everybody is being as careful.
Even people who were being more careful at
a certain point.
Meanwhile, Trump's back to doing rallies,
if you can believe that.
And we will be talking about that in a little
bit difficult situation because we must vote
like our lives depend on it.
And yet cases are rising and we want to be
safe.
We are seeing record lines at early voting.
We'll have the numbers for early voting on
today's bonus show.
People mostly wearing masks.
Orders of magnitude.
More early votes this year than in 2016.
That's great.
We have to have a plan to vote.
I will be dropping off my absentee ballot.
I think this week in person at City Hall received
it last week.
I'm ready to go.
I will film myself dropping it off and post
it as part of my get out the vote effort.
So let us know.
We'll have a question on our Instagram about
what is your plan for voting.
We are at David Pakman show on Instagram.
And if you want to see this is a great break
from politics.
If you want a two minute break from politics,
I harvested my tomatoes yesterday in advance
of the frost.
And it is stunning what I was able to get
from just three small tomato bushes.
OK, David Pakman on Instagram.
Take a two minute break from politics.
Check out my produce, my friends.
And we'll be back right after this.